it has been like that so you you
actually you saw the phone is that right
yeah yeah yeah you saw the phone that
Friday morning yes yeah and that was
around was it after half nine I I gave a
full statement to the police with the
exact ties because excuse me because my
wife's telephone call had uh a lot of
the time on it so yeah but I've given
the full set yeah yeah you're just on
the bench sure but
on the bed
[Music]
it's like that's the last three weeks
been
each day something new comes out doesn't
it yeah you know yeah yeah yeah
and and in in terms of you know
when you saw phone lead and Willow who
you you knew who Nicola was no I didn't
you knew the willow that was it wasn't
you knew you knew what the you knew I'd
seen I'd see
um but both
bought the orders of Willow yeah walking
they snug in the passport yeah whilst I
knew them back there it's like I know
your thing yes I didn't know the name
yeah yeah but you I remember you
actually telling me when you saw the
phone that the lead and Willow you were
like okay I'm gonna keep an eye on it
because something doesn't feel right I
thought somebody had gone to the toilet
in the uh you know that would have been
that was my first I got about this red
brick building here and I uh well this
this is not right and uh then there was
a conversation but my wife was trying to
ring me I was trying to ring her Penny
had wronged my wife yeah to say that she
should fasten the dog up that was that
was and Penny was the lady who actually
spotted Willow initially and saw the
phone but didn't know what was going on
with the first right yeah yeah yeah and
and then after that you know
what what happened it was just a
progression of of of things happening
you know we found out a couple of the
wallpaper on the phone we found out who
the couple were then the school was
contacted and Paul arrived yeah well
look we'll let you carry on with your
walk I know you do this every morning
Nicola did this almost every morning as
well yeah we're retracing those steps
this time three weeks ago yeah so an
important no I know juncture thank you
very much take care yeah all the best